NBC Sports will present three games on
this upcoming NFL Super Wildcard Weekend
including the NFL's first everever
exclusively live stream playoff game
that'll be Saturday night on peacock at
8 Eastern it's the Kansas City Chiefs
hosting Tyreek Hill and the Dolphins
Jason Garrett will be the game analyst
Saturday night with the Dolphins and the
Chiefs and he'll be working with Mike
too and Kaylee Hartong and the former
Cowboys coach joins us on the program
how do you prepare your team for cold
weather if you're Mike McDaniels going
into Kansas City and they're talking
about being one of the coldest games in
NFL playoff
history hey happy New Year Dan happy New
Year coach it's it's it's a real
challenge uh for anybody and and the one
thing I'd like to add though is it's a
challenge for Kansas City too you know
they've played in some of these games uh
for a lot of years but they're going to
be impacted by how cold it is and
handling the football and all of that
you know Miami has had games in New York
and Buffalo and New England so they've
had to deal with a little bit but this
seems a little extreme I don't know
there's anything you really can do in
practice uh to simulate it when you're
down there in South Florida I mean I
what do you do you know I do think you
want to talk about you know how you want
the players to dress the gloves the
sleeves all those kinds of things you
know really really get with your
equipment staff and talk those things
through and if you have to mandate some
things mandate some things but it's a
challenge it'll be a challenge for both
sides but do you coach differently in in
weather like this game plan different I
yeah I don't think there's any doubt the
weather's going to impact the game on
both sides and you know for the Dolphins
you know you could argue that they're
going to be impacted more not only
because they're from from Miami but
their style of play is so high flying
right they're such a fast team team it's
a Santa Monica Track Club every time the
ball is snapped they got so many
different guys that can attack you and
there's no doubt that when it's zero
degrees and you're playing on that grass
and the wind's blowing that slows you
down you know you know the the tough
physical team that can run the ball it
plays more to to their favor now Kansas
City on the other side they've been a
highflying outfit for a long time less
so this year they've evolved a little
bit as a team they become a more
physical team so maybe it works to their
advantage but both teams are going to be
impacted what's it like when your
quarterback maybe doesn't have the same
kind of confidence in in every receiver
like let let's say Patrick Mahomes he
knows Kelce but these other receivers
drop the ball does that is that
conscious subconscious when you're
calling plays or getting ready to throw
to a receiver oh I don't think there's
any doubt that it is especially with
where they've been you know that this is
the record setting offense of the last
four or five years and they they've been
to Heights that no other offenses have
been to for a long time and now now they
seem a lot more pedestrian a lot more
normal and I do think that what you're
talking about is real you know time and
time again when you go to a guy and you
don't get the result you want and not
only are they not making the the big
spectacular plays that we're so used to
seeing them make they're not making the
ordinary plays
and uh you know there's a great story
about Phil Jackson and and and Michael
Jordan from years ago when Phil Jackson
first got there and Jordan was already
just a star as you know and um you know
Phil kind of brought him into the
offense said you got to throw the ball
to these different guys you got to throw
it to these guys that you can't just be
you every time and he was like well that
guy drops the ball and good things don't
happen when I throw it to him and Phil
seemed to convince him to say I got that
but the more you give them chances the
more confident they're going to be and I
think that's the case that's a good
lesson for quarterbacks you know when
you're when you're dealing with young
guys who haven't had that much success
you have to keep trying to instill
confidence in them and belief in them
and maybe have to overlook some of the
drops because over time you're going to
need them and I think Rashi rice is a
great example for their team the growth
and development of this guy over the
course of the year he's a real Force now
and and I think Patrick has to be
willing to do that with some of the
other guys to to have them continue to
grow even at this late date if they want
to make a run in the playoffs I'm going
to make you owner of the
Patriots what do you
do
um you know I have such immense respect
for coach belich and what he's done I I
I think you have a conversation with him
and say okay here's where we are these
are my concerns is there a way that we
can restructure this thing and keep you
as the coach and so I would start there
instead of saying hey it's all on you to
make every decision in the organization
can we structure it in a way where um
you know we bring a general manager back
in there maybe some you're familiar with
and and let's keep going down the road
we're g to have to make some hard
decisions on staff and on players but
let's get keep this thing going short of
that if you're not satisfied with what
that answer is I think it's time to move
on and I think both guys would Embrace a
fresh start are you're the owner of the
Bears um you know this is a hard one for
me because Matt eberl worked for us in
Dallas for a long time and he's he's a
dear friend and I think you know what
he's done for the last part of this year
should be encouraging to Bears fans
particular with Justin Fields how he's
played um having said that you have to
pull back and say okay do do we have an
opportunity to go get someone who we
think can be really impactful in
differen making the obvious one would be
Jim Harbaugh are we are we comfortable
with a guy like that and then the other
decision is what do we do with the
quarterback Justin Fields has really
improved I I think he's he's shown a lot
of people how good a player he can be
but are these two guys coming out in the
draft difference making generational
players you know so so so I think you
have two really workable options
promising as a head coach and promising
as a
quarterback but then do we want to go
get the big fish so to speak so th those
those are the
discussions Jason Garrett football night
in America Studio analyst he'll be on
the call with Mike too Kaylee Hartung
that'll be Saturday night streaming on
peacock the Chiefs and the Dolphins yeah
just trying to understand what's going
on now with the coaching situation now
Mike Vel just became available why is
Mike Vel out of a job in your
opinion uh hard for me to know about the
inw workings of the
organization you know I'm such a vable
fan they did such a good job there uh
but but from the start of maybe the
middle of last year through the end of
this season they were a different team
and and I think the record shows that
they had been a team that was so hard to
beat and then they became a team that
was a lot easier to beat and uh you know
as the head coach you have to own that
clearly there was a there was a
difference in Personnel the AJ Brown
trade was certainly something I think
everyone points to as as highlighting
maybe a different a difference in
philosophy uh between the coaching staff
and the Personnel department but but it
seems like since the middle of last year
they've been different and you know what
discussions they had you know yesterday
and leading up to yesterday who knows
does he want to be there does he want to
go to New England as the next head coach
there I mean maybe those kinds of things
came up he's certainly a really good
coach and and won't be out to work long
what would be your concern or concerns
for the Cowboys hosting the Packers this
weekend uh just that they that they
don't play the way they're capable of
playing uh they're a really good team
and you know a lot of people have said
hey they've beaten teams with less than
500 record all of that well you only can
play the teams that are on your schedule
and in most of those games except for
Arizona you know they dominated them and
and they they had a rough one against
San Francisco early they had a rough one
against Philly you know uh the Miami
thing the Buffalo thing you know those
are the ones where you say hey against
the better teams how did they do but at
the end of it they won 12 out of 17 and
and they're really good in all three
phases of their team so the big
challenge for them is to go be who they
are don't let the the the the pressure
of the playoffs or you know recent
history impact you in a negative way
they're a better team than Green Bay
they should win the game particularly at
home what was it like when you're
coaching and you hear that Jerry Jones
has said something and then the media
comes over and wants to ask you about
that you know the media love
that they they love that idea of he said
this and didn't you say this before and
trying to provide a rift between us and
you you
know that that never was a big issue for
me you know because I because I knew the
conversations that Jerry Jones and I had
sometimes the perception of things were
such that oh you're over here he's over
here you're not on the same page all of
that you know we tried to have honest
conversations about things we're doing
if you had to undo some things because
maybe he was emotional after a game hey
undid it but uh you know
ultimately there are some of those
landmines that you have to deal with as
a coach particularly in a high-profile
environment it just comes with the
dinner yeah I just I felt bad for Mike
McCarthy the other day when Jerry said
hey you know his record speaks for
itself and uh you know just giving all
these you know plotted to him and then
at the very end it was basically well
we'll see how it goes game to game as
far as you know Mike McCarthy's future
so Jerry almost had the perfect response
then he had to add but we're going to
see how it goes game to game how would
you feel if you're Mike McCarthy yeah
Mike's done such a great job there he's
done a great job throughout his career
and they've been one of the better teams
in the league the last few years and you
know he knows more than anybody that you
know it's a dayto day week to week
year-to-year business and the bottom
line is winning and there's a lot of
expectation in Dallas for them to take
the next step and to go win so you know
he's done a great job kind of locking in
and keeping his team locked in you just
got to kind of move on it's all part of
it's all part of that job and he's
handled it beautifully have fun on
Saturday night there uh is your is your
wife helping you uh with your wardrobe
there on Saturday night you know we we
both decided we had to start packing
early you know and I don't know how you
pack for a game you know this is this is
New Territory For Me 0 degrees calling a
game in Kansas City with the window open
don't don't wear gloves when you're on
camera like act tough okay yeah don't
wear gloves on camera well just when
they go to you in the booth there I mean
too is going to have gloves on I know
that really yeah but you know what don't
be afraid to not have the Hat on now
once the camera's off of you you can
bundle up but I think you know you got
to show that you're tough your East
Coast tough yeah I don't think hat right
we can't do a hat n right well it
depends on how long you're on camera
coach yeah you're exactly right yeah
don't do ear months okay I think quick
changes are going to be
critical uh good to talk to you safe
travels thank you thanks always good
talking to you Happy New Year to you
thank you you too coach Jason Garrett
football night in America and uh NBC
Sports is going to present the uh super
Wildcard Weekend the first ever
exclusively live streamed playoff game
this Saturday night on peacock at 8
Eastern and they're talking about being
one of the coldest games on record
certainly in playoff history